[Music]
the tower of london one of the most
famous towers out there next to the
sears tower and the leaning tower of
pisa a place where tourists go to gawk
at history uncomfortably large and bold
ravens and ask the timeless question why
are the guards called beefeaters but
enough jokes this iconic sight is no
laughing matter the tower is best known
for its blood-soaked history as the site
of hundreds of imprisonments and
executions over the years as well as a
fair share of murders three queens anne
boleyn jane grey and catherine howard
lost their heads there edward v and
richard duke of york were found murdered
there still only children when they died
king henry vi was killed during his
prayers in his private chapel the list
goes on and on and the blood continues
to flow it is no surprise that many
consider the tower of london to be among
the most haunted places in the world few
locals have seen such an intense
concentration of violent tragic death
and misery there are reports of queen
anne bolin wandering the halls with her
severed head tucked under her arm the
little murdered princes frolicking
through the corridors in the dead of
night and the countess of salisbury
reenacting her horrific execution in
which she was hacked to death as she
fled if you're at all enthused in
british royal history you may know about
all these people and their grisly ends
already but what you may not know about
is a formerly imprisoned man known as
the wizard earl henry percy 9th earl of
northrumberland also known as wizard
earl due to his involvement in the
occult was imprisoned in the tower of
london in the late 1590s though he was a
prisoner he lived a relatively
comfortable life and was allowed to
continue his research and build a small
library of books and other academic
materials in his room he died in
november of 1632 and the secrets of his
research died with him that is until
martin tower was being renovated
hundreds of years later during the
process of renovations to the martin
tower a hidden chamber was discovered
beneath the tower's structure it did not
appear on any official blueprints of the
building the chamber contained scattered
notes and papers and a sturdy iron door
despite several attempts the door could
not be opened by any ordinary means
further investigation of the papers
found in the chamber revealed that they
were research notes penned by henry
percy who is thought to have created the
chamber and the door within it the notes
were unusual and ominous hinting at a
sense of otherworldly danger a
particularly unsettling note was an
unsent letter from henry percy to famed
playwright christopher marlowe in the
letter percy apologizes to marlowe for
refusing to accept his warning about
building the janus gate a significant
term as janus is the roman deity that
represents buildings transitions and
passageways the letter also references a
cursed play most likely the hanged
king's tragedy or
scp-701 which percy begs marlow to
destroy he ends the letter by saying
that he has sealed the gate permitting
only the enlightened to enter it so that
they might perhaps see what percy could
not the letter concludes damn that
metropolis of blood that terrible realm
and its ancient countless crimes consign
thy play to the fire deny thy vile
patron and arrived thee from this
madness we would feign welcome thee back
into the night more troubling perhaps
than the contents of the letter itself
is the date it was to be sent may 30th
1593 the day before marlow was murdered
suspecting the presence of an anomalous
artifact the janus gate referenced in
percy's notes and letters the crown
hurriedly contacted the scp foundation
and requested they perform a thorough
investigation what they found was unlike
anything the foundation has ever
encountered before or since henry percy
was speaking truthfully in his letter he
did seal off the door in his secret
chamber the only way to open it is to
complete a series of alchemical
instructions similar to those used in
the creation of a philosopher's stone a
resident alchemy expert at the
foundation assisted in finding the
solution and for better or for worse the
janus gate was unlocked for observation
beyond the gate lies a city known as
scp-2264-b
the city is extra-dimensional matching
no known location on earth or anywhere
else upon entering the city the smell of
dried flowers and old books greets you
you glance up at the sky to find it an
eerie yellow spotted with infinite
glittering black stars if you look down
at yourself you will find that your
clothes have disappeared replaced with a
tire that would not be out of place at a
masquerade ball your face is adorned
with a venetian mask that you cannot
remove no matter how hard you try until
you have left this strange world and
passed back through the gate if you
pause to take in the sights of the city
around you you will find buildings
carved from one single undetermined
material all in black white yellow or
red these are the only colors present in
the city in the distance a viscous black
ocean laps at the shore on all sides
though the ominous black liquid inset
ocean is anything but water the city
though it has been proven to exist in a
corporeal state has the quality of a
lucid dream operatives inside of it
report difficulty concentrating citing a
feeling of hypnogic malaise inability to
control their impulses and trouble
describing what they saw and did inside
of the city once they have returned to
the regular world the dimension seems to
run on dream logic best described in the
movie inception not everything makes
sense and transitions between place and
time seem muddy to say the least after
several expeditions that failed to
return conclusive coherent observations
about the city's nature another
exploration was planned chosen for his
experience with altered states mainly
lucid dreaming and hallucinogenic drugs
dr calixto nevaez was selected to lead
this exploration upon entering
scp-2264-b for his first exploration
most of dr nevaez's colleagues split off
from him to join in the decadent
celebrations in the palace he resisted
this temptation though of course he
considered it for a moment and continued
on with his investigation of the city he
made several significant discoveries
over the course of this first expedition
which informed the foundation's
perspective on the city going forward
first he realized that the city somehow
universally translates language no
matter what a person's native tongue is
they will hear the inhabitants of the
city speaking in it some of dr nevaez's
colleagues heard the citizen speaking
english while he heard them speaking in
his native spanish it is unclear how
this instantaneous translation is
accomplished second he learned the name
of the city a lagada a city-state
bordering something referred to only as
the never meant to provide a little
context and clarification the city of
alagadda is a nexus point for a whole
multiverse of hedonists countless
entities from every conceivable
dimension turn up here to sample its
legendary pleasures think of it almost
like a multi-dimensional cancun during
spring break he was given this
information by a foreign scholar known
as the wandsman of kulmanas a robed
creature in a bird-like mask the
wandsman was also able to provide some
insight into the political power
structure of aligata providing dr nevaez
with his third piece of critical new
information the city is overseen by four
masked lords the black lord wear of the
anguished mask the white lord wearer of
the diligent mask the yellow lord wearer
of the odious mask and the red lord
wearer of the mirthful mask these
powerful entities act as advisors to the
city's mighty king who many of the
travelers in the city sought to favor
from the wandsman warned about each of
these lords stating that in spite of
their different names they are all
equally dangerous they also warned
against interacting with the ambassador
of alagadda after this illuminating
conversation dr nevaez gathered the rest
of his colleagues and returned to the
real world on his second expedition into
alagadda dr nevaez immediately sought
out the wandsman of kulmanas the
wandsman expressed concern for dr nevaez
and his team warning them the ambassador
of alagata will soon return from
arientum and only the mad shall remain i
suggest you leave post-haze for i intend
the same when pressed on the subject of
adityam the wantsman explained that it
is a terrible city filled with equally
terrible people it is said that the
grand carces of arithm serves the
designs of an elder being a horror
thought to rival even the hanged king of
alagadda before dr nevaez could gather
any more answers the wandsmen stopped
becoming clearly frightened and said i
sense the ambassador of alagadda has
returned i take my leave of this place
and i suggest you do the same flee do
not delay the wandsman promptly exited
through the nearest store following dr
nevaez's expeditions the foundation
appointed a task force of agents trained
in hand-to-hand combat and
counter-occult strategies to go back
into alagadda the task force nicknamed
the abyss gazers was to seek out the
king and ambassador of alagadda and
determined the level of threat they
might pose to humanity 12 agents were
sent in and only one agent alexander
papadopoulos came back alive the other
11 are presumed dead or lost forever
agent papadopoulos was found unconscious
and in critical condition outside of the
entrance to alagadda a physical exam was
conducted revealing broken bones
throughout his entire body as well as
severe internal bleeding he was in the
hospital for three weeks before the
foundation determined him healthy enough
for an interview the interview was
conducted by dr laxmi narang and allowed
the foundation to get a sense of what
agent papadopoulos witnessed inside the
city and what happened to the other 11
team members the team managed to locate
the palace struggling with the dreamlike
effect of the city on the mind and the
lack of ability to determine how much
time had passed while they were there as
the group descended deeper into the
palace it became more convoluted and
labyrinthine they spent most of their
time descending a staircase traveling
deeper and deeper when they reached the
bottom of the staircase suddenly they
were outside of the palace again as if
they never went inside except everything
was a little bit different wrong somehow
the whole world looked dark and drained
of color bathed in hazy gray light there
were no people to be seen and the
buildings looked run down and abandoned
they walked back into the palace from
this strange new location and began to
hear whispering not just in their ears
but in their very minds the ambassador
of alagadda had found them it appeared
before them a tall thin dark figure with
no face no mouth no eyes somehow it
spoke in a language none of the team
could understand
and it laughed as it watched unable to
control themselves the team began to
tear each other apart flesh ripped
organs collapsed bones shattered and
none of them could stop themselves until
agent papadopoulos was the only one left
alive he was not left alive by mistake
the ambassador left him living in order
to pass on the message of its existence
it dragged his limp body into the
chambers of the king and forced him to
look upon its twisted form his exact
terrifying words of the account paint a
gruesome picture eventually
we stopped
and it lifted me into the air
help me up before the throne
there i saw the king
it was anchored in place
hollowed pawns around its corpse like
hands and throat its face
hidden beneath the veil impish creatures
crawled all over it
caressing its twitching body as if
intending comfort
while others pulled the tethers even
tighter
the king trembled and quivered and i saw
the pale tendrils slither in and out of
its tattered robes
i looked on as the veil was lifted at
this point in this interview the agent
became inconsolable he begged to be
killed a request
which was denied before the interview
ended the agent said a god shaped all
the barren desolation of a fallen and
failed creation
you see the light of long dead
stars your existence is nothing but an
echo of a tie god scrapes
the unseen convergence
surrounds you
and tightens
like a noose after the interview agent
papadopoulos refused food and water and
repeatedly requested to be terminated
this request was denied every time and
he was given a feeding tube for
nutrients after the revelations in the
papadopoulos interview the foundation
suspended all research expeditions into
alagadda it is difficult to hide
scp-2264 from the public due to the
public nature of the building the
gateway is located in because the tower
of london cannot be shut off to the
public the foundation has focused on
hiding the gateway from anyone who might
accidentally stumble upon it the
government of the united kingdom and the
foundation worked together to build a
secret passage to scp-22
accessible only to authorized personnel
the original entrance has been walled
off meanwhile beyond the gate elega
continues in its strange twisted ways we
do not know what the ambassador wants or
the nature of the other beings lurking
within the city walls but we can only
hope that they never find their way
through the gate to us now go check out
scp-260
pan-dimensional vending machine and
scp-001 the spiral path for more extra
dimensional oddities